hey guys I'm Ryan right hi I'm Veronica
Zeus and I'm cat Das and we're gonna
watch the trailer today for Nightcrawler
it's a Jake Gyllenhaal film saw the
first trailer don't know much about it
mic wasn't working earlier so I'm just
repeating what I said earlier yeah we
had a little funny bit that we did again
that we didn't that we couldn't get on
camera because of the audio so let's try
do it again real fast okay it was really
in the moment we didn't plan it you
cannot you can't just read you can't
just redo it but somebody will try to
give you an effect okay all right here
we go
what did I say they let me into it I
don't know yeah sitting I was sitting
like this and I said I don't know how to
sit when I'm in between two women which
went sets joke and I went no sex show
today no because I'm with this lady mine
and I'm hers and then I went cats
although I'm better-looking in you
that's what makes it funny because I'm
clearly not but I'm very cocky like that
so I really believe I am actually so
catch we cannot ever flirt it I cannot
hit on you because I know you're the one
mainly hitting on me like all the videos
if you watch them it's mainly you really
you just have to back off because I'm
with this special lady now all right
I'll do my best so let's watch the
trailer
Nightcrawler that's what we should call
my dude she called it she calling and I
could look left like a feel left out
right now let's just make her feel
uncomfortable for something just make
this letting this whole episode about us
and not not if you included the whole
time they're eating popcorn the whole
time
[Music]
excuse me sir
I'm most encouraged I'm hard worker I
set high goals my motto is if you want
to win the lottery you have to make the
money to buy a ticket so what do you say
it start tomorrow even why not tonight
well I'm not hiring la so cool that's
really creepy
[Music]
on television Morning News it bleeds it
leads
are you currently he's having trouble
getting your dog yes I film breaking
stories maybe some item this morning you
favor carjacking don't lie Madeline TV
your cell phone yeah is that GPS
congratulations you're hired
please create clicks right so many more
ask you to do anything I wouldn't do
myself laughs excuse me I have something
we'll be very excited about yeah good I
I want you to contact me wha so [ __ ]
out this think of our music has to
screaming over running down the street
they're so good you will be seeing me
again
oh sweet
Slick's [ __ ] awesome
[Music]
find a person that drove that car I'm
detective hyeri I think you withheld
information that would be very
unprofessional things
[Music]
something people can't turn away from I
[Music]
think was inspiring Oh mr. Reichel in
life rockin i should pretty freakin good
oh man what an intriguing news story
yeah very new very now I've never heard
of anything like that's a really
interesting angle yeah you're you do
journalism too so this would be pretty
down your feelings yeah she's really
understood it seeing it I am I hope you
do want your approach and Jake
Gyllenhaal look so [ __ ] creepy with
that hair like the faces yeah no I he's
claimed we were talking about this
before we shot like Jake Johan I think
it's really just [ __ ] he's mind-blowing
now and a lot of these movies man I
loved him in prisoners I loved him and
end of watch I mean when I first started
really like I was like he's really
didn't source code and then that's how
his other movies I'm like wow this guy's
fantastic enemy super excited about this
yeah the performance looks great the
[ __ ] story looks good the way shot
looks like beautiful like I like movies
I know how to capture la the beautiful
light like in a beautiful dark light
like dry I know I thought I Drive we
talked about driving and Ryan Gosling
several times a day he's going on man I
do love that man he's one committed so
is that hard for you guys having just
Ryan ever come between you
yes sometimes and also Jerry yeah I just
love Jerry good he's the best
Jerry's the best sure yeah no I really
do I really do want to see this Ike yeah
I'm pretty stoked but it's kind of it's
cool movie to release on Halloween like
I feel like I will be there on Halloween
because it is kind of scary you know and
I have to admit I haven't really seen
many of his good movies I had
they like him that much and now I'm
looking forward to seeing this so he was
brilliant in Prince of Persia
I love Oh was he I didn't guess that I
thought that was an interesting choice I
loved Brokeback Mountain I loved it but
I just wasn't I wasn't happy with the
performance so I'm looking forward to
seeing this that I don't want to judge
him like based on just a few of his
projects yeah
all right guys well if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects thank you
what is love yes veronica has a channel
too just like music and blogging stuff
almost a thousand subscribers well it's
awesome
so let's what so cared of thousand
almost there guys and I've been telling
this woman lady only a friend I got this
covered right yeah okay that she should
start up a YouTube channel for the
longest time and a lot of you guys
who've seen a lot of her videos want her
to start up a channel it's Kat she's an
interesting character she's an engineer
managed to get didn't seek a cue to get
clever cat she does like journalism and
she has a lot of skills archery know
this artist she is tortured you archery
too I've done stuff I've played around
[ __ ] she's one of the female rejects
are what does it Archer Archer ists what
what is it aren't you aren't sure you're
an archer I know I'm not an archer just
like playing around say that's all
that's I I just was like fine it's
really fun there's actually a group in
the valley why would you plan to shoot
girls on the trip shoot art that are not
you do archery I just want you to look
the best but no can't does a lot of [ __ ]
and acts and does a bunch of Arts at art
show recently yeah she's good she's good
I didn't know these things is my first
day meeting Kat so I know I'm so excited
we finally get to meet ya oh you some
shoutouts
what do we got yay shut up
whoo Steve Thomas he wants a shout-out
please please you guys are freaking
awesome Steve Thomas you shall get a
shout-out my friend Steve was actually
my father's name my father was a drinker
and a being I'm trapped teach my girl
let him try to shake my father today
haha she's almost there this isn't about
my relationship with Veronica Steve this
channel has really changed we're just
trying to have a heart to the channels
all that's the whole point of this
marketing scheme we gotta go but Steve
listen my friend Steve and Thomas are
good names of their bull from the Bible
Thomas one of the followers of Jesus and
Steve Adams Steve ah that's a she's with
me I wasn't paying attention with that
and this is why she always hid something
I'm like back off lady I'm taking it's
tough just have to respect that you have
to respect that cat funny you're
excluded from this video many ways cats
Slenderman Slenderman is a scary
character from a game he wants a
shout-out I can i have a shout out to
your special shout out list i'll watch
your channel every day you guys rule
dude Slenderman Slenderman you know in
the shadows yes that is the that is the
character I think it's lovely peach
juice right that could be at the center
of it girl I can make a penis joke
yes you're making this Oh slender man
huh
lurking in the shadows I'll tell you
what's lurking in the shadows certainly
not slender though you know what I mean
a special shout-out list so Kazuma
Kenway he sort of made a interesting
deal with me he said I'm glad you liked
it now my advice watch the rest of the
twenty haight Godzilla movies with Jerry
because he knows them all if you pretend
you are a little kid to collect I wanna
read all that okay said if you want
something to talk about and to make
videos i will post news and other
trailers videos on your discussion page
but i will only post it if you make the
videos out of it and give me a shout out
mention me in the video thanks take it
easy
nah this guy yeah like he wants like a
15% cut or something this guy really
struck up a deal with so if you post
news and other traditionally as long as
i just keep you know acknowledging and
do videos of it you will stay subscribed
and I must give you a shout out so kazoo
Mike anyway this is your shoutout my
Japanese write like cool name too
it's kind of hot Oh what wasn't is you
usually what hear anything I'm out of
this this is between you guys gotta
learn to work out here I don't
understand what's gonna you even know
this guy you just called him hot like
you're in front of me so what you should
talk to she's she's in a relationship
she's not dead it's a hot name yeah she
didn't say that to the guy what a voice
this kinda wants to [ __ ] her anything
she wants to do something whenever you
do you live another deal with it what
are you doing we joke we joke we kid we
kid yeah real [ __ ] funny cuz of
office